it's only been the last few hundred
years or so that Western civilization
has been putting art in museums at least
museums resembling the public
institutions we know today before this
for most art served other purposes what
we call fine art today was in fact
primarily how people experienced an
aesthetic dimension of religion
paintings sculpture textiles and
illuminations were the media of their
time supplying vivid imagery to
accompany the stories of the day
in this sense Western art shared a
utilitarian purpose with other cultures
around the world some of whose languages
incidentally have no word for art
so how do we define what we call art
generally speaking what we're talking
about here is work that visually
communicates meaning beyond language
either through representation or the
arrangement of visual elements in space
evidence of this power of iconography or
ability of images to convey meaning can
be found in abundance if we look at art
from the histories of our major world
religions almost all have at one time or
another in their history gone through
some sort of an iconic phase an icon ism
prohibits any visual depiction of the
divine this is done in order to avoid
idolatry or confusion between the
representation of divinity and divinity
itself keeping it real so to speak in
the relationship between the individual
and the divine
however this can be a challenge to
maintain given that the urge to visually
represent and interpret the world around
us is a compulsion difficult to suppress
for example even today where the
depiction of Allah or the Prophet
Muhammad is prohibited an abstract
celebration of the divine can still be
found in arabesque patterns of Islamic
textile design with masterful flourishes
of brushwork in Arabic calligraphy where
the words of the Prophet assume a dual
role is both literature and visual art
likewise in art from the early periods
of Christianity and Buddhism the divine
presence of the Christ and the Buddha do
not appear in human form but are
represented by symbols in each case
iconographic reference is employed as a
form of reverence
anthropomorphic representation or
depiction in human form eventually
became widespread in these religions
only centuries later under the influence
of the cultural traditions surrounding
them
historically speaking the public
appreciation of visual art in terms
other than traditional religious or
social function is a relatively new
concept today we fetishize the fetish so
to speak we go to museums to see art
from the ages but our experience of it
there is drastically removed from the
context in which it was originally
intended to be seen
it might be said that the modern viewer
lacks the richness of engagement that
she has with contemporary art which has
been created relevant to her time and
speaks her cultural language
it might also be said that the history
of what we call art is a conversation
that continues on as our contemporary
present passes into what will be some
future generations classical past it's a
conversation that reflects the
ideologies mythologies belief systems
and taboos and so much more of the world
in which it was made
but this is not to say that work from
another age made to serve a particular
function in that time is dead or has
nothing to offer the modern viewer even
though in a museum setting works of art
from different places and times are
presented alongside each other isolated
from their original settings the
juxtaposition has benefits exhibits are
organized by curators or people who've
made a career out of their ability to
recontextualize or remix cultural
artifacts in a collective presentation
as viewers were then able to consider
the art in terms of a common theme that
might not be apparent in a particular
work until you see it alongside another
and new meanings can be derived and
reflected upon
if we're so inclined we might even start
to see every work of art as a
complementary part of some undefined
unified whole of past human experience a
trail that leads right to our doorstep
and continues on with us open to anyone
who wants to explore it